[Musique]
bienvenue très heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce premier numéro de la nouvelle
saison d' enquête de région ici au
château de bussy-rabutin en côte d'or
l'un des lieux emblématiques du loto du
patrimoine initiée par stéphane bern
dans le cadre de sa mission confiée par
le président de la république dans cette
émission on va s'intéresser à notre
patrimoine en bourgogne franche comté
mais surtout à ceux qui le font vivre
qui tente de le préserver également ce
sont des propriétaires privés des
associations des bénévoles les
collectivités locales ou même l'état ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'ils sont tous
passionnés de patrimoine
[Musique]
la vie de château ça peut coûter cher
pour financer la belle demeure familiale
un père et son fils n'hésite pas à
accueillir entre deux visites guidées de
fort brouillard au coeur
j'ai hésité longuement parce que pour
moi je voyais des cailloux des canettes
un peu d'eux un kick et j'étais un peu
réservés
[Musique]
jeune étudiant ou simples passionnés ils
viennent du monde entier sur les
chantiers de notre région ils sont tous
animés par une même ambition préserver
nos monuments historiques
vous allez me préparer donc une double
avec
dont 4 de sable jaune et 4 de sable
rouge salins les bains un nom qui
résonne une réalité qui détonne son
patrimoine est une richesse qui se
dégrade comme les relations entre les
élus et certains habitants
vous avez acheté il ya quatre ans vous
deviez rénové vous avez laissé le bien
courir aux gens non habités comme ça
gêne aujourd'hui non monsieur nous avons
des photos des artisans la sauvegarde du
patrimoine vitrailliste ébéniste
couvreur ces passionnés s'attache aussi
à transmettre leur savoir faire
j'espère que oui au niveau des chantiers
tout se procurer après ça coûte
tellement cher la veuve que la peau
grande qui peut se procurer un pot
commun particulier par exemple très cher
patrimoine s'est tout de suite par an 4
de région
[Musique]
on part d'abord à la rencontre de
châtelain hors norme la famille potet
qui depuis plus de 40 ans possède l'un
des plus beaux mais aussi l'un des plus
grands châteaux de bourgogne franche
comté leur relation passionnée mais
coûteuse avec cette déraisonnable
demeure du xixème siècle n'a jamais
cessé mais ils doivent en permanence
trouver les ressources pour l'entretenir
et vous allez voir qu'il ne manque pas
d'idées
[Musique]
inutile de le nier un jour ou l'autre
nous avons tous rêvé d'être le seigneur
du château
[Musique]
surtout lorsque le quotidien de vos
voisins évoque étrangement une série
télévisée
mais pour jouer au châtelard il ne
suffit pas d'être bien né
il faut aussi avoir la main verte
[Musique]
chaque semaine bazin jules potet
s'occupe de l'entretien du château
familial
c'est son père qui l'a acheté comme ça
sur un coup de tête
c'était il ya 40 ans à l'époque
ce parisien rouler en rolls et selon lui
personne ne voulait de cette immense
demeure construite au 19e siècle pour
avoir un château fort et riche et c'est
vrai que quand je suis arrivé ici
j'étais jeune j'étais beau j'étais riche
et j'étais intelligent il reste plus
grand chose de tout ça car il a un
appétit féroce sur mon compte en banque
il ya toujours quelque chose à réparer
il ya toujours quelque chose à arranger
je suis le spécialiste des toilettes
bouchées des tuiles qui tombe il a du
caractère le châtelain de villersexel il
se soucie peu des honneurs et des
notables n aime pas vraiment qu'on
vienne l'enquiquiner sur ses terres dieu
sait si j'agace dieu sait si les gens
m'aiment et me détestent mais je survis
allègrement et je pense que comme ce
sont les meilleurs qui partait premier
je serais sûrement dans les derniers
depuis deux ans ses bases un jeu l'un
des enfants de la famille qui gère ce
château qui compte des dizaines de
pièces on est une structure très
familial on a à peu près cinq employés
la plus grosse charge c'est les salaires
et puis les charges qui sont annexés on
pour être dans le vert ou en tout cas
pas perdre d'argent juste avec sa faux
atteindre cent mille euros
voilà juste pour couvrir les charges
annuelles
[Musique]
alors petit jeu vont commencer est ce
que vous avez remarqué la différence
entre l'aide de gauche celle de droite
et pour gagner un peu d'argent on
organise ici des visites guidées 18
euros par personne pour une petite leçon
d'histoire milieu de la pièce un lustre
en bronze plusieurs centaines de kilos
250 à 300 kg au bas mot j'essaie
d'éviter d'en parler quand je reçois des
gens en visite guidée qui prennent le
petit déjeuner ici parce que tous ces
lustres à l'époque ont eu tendance à
tomber à cause de leur propre poids iam
room to host à et götze romanow come
back to you cas on peut même dormir chez
la femme hypothèques qui propose des
chambres d'hôtes
l'été les touristes étrangers raffolent
de la formule oui c'est vraiment très
beau et très romantique et vous avez
découvert ce château comment par
internet et pour attirer encore plus de
monde
le jeune châtelain sert les prix avec
des nuitées à moins de 100 euros
je considère qu'on est à villersexel
qu'on est en haute saône et que ce qu'on
peut pratiquer au niveau tarif c'est 20
% plus cher qu'un hôtel normal
il ya les visites guidées les chambres
d'hôtes mais aussi des séminaires ou des
vernissages
[Musique]
sans oublier bien sûr les mariages les
journées de base un jules comme de sa
famille sont souvent bien remplie et les
demandes parfois étonnantes
on reçoit un stage de danse que chez
nous depuis qui vient tous les ans
depuis 20 ans et donc aujourd'hui
veulent faire de la danse baroque avec
des verres donc je leur fournis les
verres à pied pour faire leurs danses
[Musique]
mais pour accroître la notoriété du
château les potins ont accepté
d'accueillir un événement qui aurait
fait peur à n'importe quel châtelain la
rencontre était improbable tant leur
univers sont différents mais le courant
est très bien passé entre monsieur côté
soudain et le musicien francis décamps
le sympa un festival de rock dans le
parc du château
le voilà le projet un peu fou du
claviériste qui fut l'un des fondateurs
du groupe ange
j'ai hésité longuement j'ai hésité
longuement parce que pour moi je voyais
des cailloux des canettes un peu de un
kick et j'étais un peu réservés et si ça
s'est déroulé c'est justement parce que
suivent ça s'est bien passé entre nous
deux ça aurait été un autre et je
n'aurais peut-être pas fait remarquer
s'il y aurait pas eu de château il
l'aurait pas fait non plus depuis quatre
ans le château de villersexel se
transforme l'été en temple du rock
progressif
le rendez vous est même devenu le plus
important du genre en france
je suis rentré dans le pas j'ai dit
c'est là c'est dégueulasse ça ya de la
magie
parce que c'est faire un festival c'est
pas amener des gens comme des moutons à
les entasser pour écouter de la musique
et pour partager une soirée avec des
artistes mais ces dix ans des amis dans
un endroit où il ya imaginer
[Musique]
beaucoup d'objets différents dans ce
château elle ne sut attend beaucoup de
piano
je crois qu'ils collectionnent les
pianos une musique parfois expérimental
qui a même ses vedettes comme steve
hogarth du groupe mario marchand met un
peu plus loin juste un kilomètre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le chacun assistera re mon concert ces
soirées il préfère les passer dans les
salons de ce château qu'il a patiemment
remeubler au fil du temps on vous a déjà
proposé de le racheter le château
oui on m'a proposé une fois une mallette
avec record millions d'euros dans une
mallette et c'était le premier versement
de trois essais tête ou du cash et je me
pose encore la question maintenant de
savoir pourquoi j'ai dit non si c'est
par peur ou si c'est par maurage c'est
vrai que j'ai des raisons de dire non
affective et puis j'ai des raisons que
j'estime logique ses 40 ans de travail
au château de villersexel son pays sans
rien quoi ccc et j'ai bouffé tout mon
héritage c'est plusieurs centaines de
milles euros ccc pour nous
[Musique]
vous gagnez de l'argent et qui à château
je sais pas faudra venir dans 20 ans je
sais pas encore je pense
on peut y gagner de l'argent mais j'ai
pas encore la certitude
depuis 40 ans la famille potet
s'accroche à son rêve et continue de
chérir cette demeure magnifique et
capricieuse qui vous envoûtent la nuit
pour mieux vous faire les poches au
petit matin
[Musique]
je
françois xavier verger vous êtes
l'administrateur de ce château de
bussy-rabutin ici en côte d'or on va
parler de l'organisation de ce château
mais peut-être avant un mot de
l'histoire des lieux c'est un château du
moyen-âge transformé à la renaissance et
aménagé par le camp de bussy-rabutin au
17ème siècle
donc on est sur plusieurs siècles
plusieurs décors plusieurs plusieurs
styles d'architecturé un château qui a
longtemps était un château privé avec
différentes familles il a appartenu à
différents talents
oui depuis les comptes de bussy jusque
là révolution française c'est une chose
le château privé à partie la révolution
le château change de mains jusque en
1930 où l'état donc achète le château et
le confier aux monuments nationaux à
l'époque la caisse des monuments
historiques
aujourd'hui c'est le centre des
monuments nationaux qui gère ce château
vous êtes l'administrateur stade vous
représentez ici le ministère de la
culture
oui c'est le centre des monuments
nationaux qui gère en france sans
monument de l'arc de triomphe au mont
saint michel à carcassonne est ici en
bourgogne cluny et bussy rabutin comment
se fait le choix parce que c'est par
opportunité ou c'est du fait de
l'importance de certains monuments dans
le choix c'est un choix de
d'opportunités en effet ce sont parfois
des dons ce sont parfois des
acquisitions quand le patrimoine était
menacée et puis c'est bien sûr
l'histoire
l'héritage de l'histoire de france les
résidences royales du monument de la
nation alors on s'intéresse dans cette
émission à tous ceux qui protègent
sauvegarde le patrimoine vous en êtes
vous et tous les acteurs du ministère de
la culture est ce que c'est plus facile
de sauvegarder un patrimoine qui
finalement appartient à l'état
c'est peut-être plus facile que
lorsqu'on est un propriétaire privé où
elle investit ses propres moyens
oui on vient de voir un château en haute
saône qui est une propriété privée et où
le propriétaire se débat un petit peu
quand même
incontestablement nous nous sollicitons
des moyens auprès de notre tutelle aux
prémices à la culture aux pandémies
nationaux et nous les engageons de
manière à maintenir ce monument dans le
meilleur état de conservation
on n'a pas exactement une condition
d'activité que propriétaire privé bien
sûr
[Musique]
alors ses châteaux ses grandes bâtisses
évidemment elle demande beaucoup
d'entretien
d'autant plus qu'il ya trente mille
visiteurs par an ici à bucarest a donc
dû passage et sa demande de
l'organisation et de l'entretien ça
coûte cher on imagine oui nous avons une
équipe qui est dévolue à deux fonctions
bien sûr l'accueil des visiteurs
la présentation du monument des visites
mais aussi la conservation du monument
serre que cette équipe est là pour
vérifier que les meubles et tableaux les
textiles mais aussi l'immeuble en
lui-même vont bien et c'est eux qui nous
signalent une intervention à mener sur
par exemple des insectes qui mangent de
bois ou une moisissure ou que sais-je
donc l'équipe du monument à cette double
fonction d'accueil et de conservation
préventive et à l'équipe de
l'administration du monument qui elle
engage les moyens un lien bien sûr avec
le siège de l'établissement et la drac
ce château de bussy-rabutin a été choisi
pour être un des sites emblématiques du
loto de patrimoine du patrimoine
organisées par par stéphane bern à la
demande du président de la république
e quand vous l'avez appris ça vous a
fait quoi c'est une grande joie parce
que ça ça va déclencher pour nous des
chantiers qui sont indispensables
donc on a eu cette satisfaction de
pouvoir se dire qu'on allait agir d'une
manière plus importante que que nos
seuls moyens
ça veut dire que si ce loto et ce jeu de
grattage on va pouvoir même gratter le
le château de bussy-rabutin lui-même ont
une destination précise déjà défini vous
savez que si c'est de l'auto fonctionne
vous allez restaurer telle ou telle
chose
en effet nous avons proposé une série de
chantiers la mission de stéphane bern et
ça a été validée donc nous savons que
nous allons engager un chantier dans ce
qu'on appelle l sarcus qu'il/elle de
l'appartement de madame de bussy-rabutin
que les propriétaires du même siècle
avait aménagé pour leur résidence
c'est cet ensemble de pièces qui
aujourd'hui exige un chantier important
[Musique]
de m
m
alors que certains choisissent de passer
leurs vacances d'été à la mer d'autres
s'engagent pour préserver le patrimoine
depuis 1966 la fédération d'associations
remparts mobilise des bénévoles l'été
pour restaurer églises châteaux et
autres monuments historiques
parmi eux de nombreux jeunes certains
venus de très loin
nous en avons suivi 3 ils sont là pour
des motivations très différents ils sont
chaque année des dizaines à s'engager
sur ces chantiers d'été tous bénévoles
venus du monde entier
expérimenté ou totalement novice leur
objectif est le même
sauvegarder notre patrimoine nous avons
suivi alexandra passionné d'archéologie
depuis l'enfance jade étudiante en
histoire de l'art et futurs
restauratrice abbas réfugiés iraniens
arrivé en france l'année dernière
il est à peine 7 heures début d'une
journée de chantier pour alexandra et
ses collègues
leur mission consolider les ruines de ce
site archéologique vieux de 4300 ans
vous allez me préparer donc une double
avec dont 4 de sable jaune et 4 de sable
rouge
vous allez ma corpore a tous à un saut
et demie de show blanche et 1/2 saut de
l'autre choc nous a emmenés alexandra et
étudiantes et si elle a décidé de passer
ses vacances les mains dans la chaux
c'est surtout pour la vie en
collectivité
les rencontres on est plein de deux
jeunes ou moins jeunes à venir ici de
deux pays différents
donc c'est pour rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes de nouvelles cultures
par exemple un dans notre groupe il ya
une personne qui vient d'afghanistan une
autre du nigeria soudan maroc
donc c'est assez incroyable de tous des
jeunes ensemble à discuter de comment on
voit le monde ce que nous on a appris
abbas lui a fui son pays d'origine
l'iran et est arrivé en france il ya un
an malgré la barrière de la langue
il cherche aussi les rencontres pour
mieux s'intégrer
son rêve c'est de devenir mécanicien
alors avant de réparer un jour des
véhicules il renforce l'étanchéité de
cette péniche moyen pour lui de garder
la tête hors de l'eau
je voulais avoir de l'expérience voir
comment on travaille ici en france je
trouve que c'est très intéressant pour
moi c'est encore mieux que ce que
j'espérais
[Musique]
c'est la première fois qu'ils
participent à un chantier d'été tout
comme alexandra d'éclat mortier
approprié qu'il est trop raide
automatiquement ces trois la presse
locale isna
sinon bah ce procès est simplement est
la grosse pointure venir ici était pour
elle une évidence
l'archéologie c'est sa passion depuis
tout petit j'ai la chance d'être né au
cap d'agde dans le sud
lier un ancien port grec donc en fait
déconstruit baigne un peu loin dans la
mer on peut vite voir des anciennes
amphores etc
c'est vrai que mon père dès fois en
ramener à la maison donc je trouve ça
toujours été pleins depuis petit j'ai
grandi avec ça un peu
jade elle a grandi avec la peinture et
c'est dans cette église du 19e siècle
qu'elle a trouvé son bonheur
d'immenses fresques à restaurer du pain
béni pour cette étudiante en histoire de
l'art qui veut faire de la restauration
son métier en fait très très longtemps
je pratique la peinture et je voulais
absolument un métier qui sont en
relation avec cette pratique est
pourtant en fait la réparation cette
terre moyens d'avoir tout ce que j'aime
dans un seul métier donc pouvoir admirer
des peintures d'avoir son côté pratique
et aussi d'avoir une histoire dollars je
suis passionnée et aussi le côté
scientifique fait ça rassemble tout ce
que j'aime dans une seule critique film
[Musique]
les bénévoles sont encadrés par des
professionnels des conseils avisés pour
progresser rapidement
c'est qu'en fait tu calcules à partir de
là j'ai vraiment ici pour apprendre le
métier et comment ça se passe quand on
se donne des conseils
bah tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui je ne
savais pas il ya deux semaines et j'ai
appris une chose
[Musique]
samedi jour maintenant je sais restaurer
un mur je poussais c'est dingue moi qui
savais qui suit pas très manuelle mais
là on nous a appris avec l'aide de paul
eut donc la taille hausse de pierre de
le démolir un mur de garder les bonnes
pierre ce qui est pas évident si les
remonter quelle pierre à la bonne place
et de voir qu'on a besoin de l'aide de
toute une équipe
c'est bon ici ce sont aussi des
relations qui se construisent abbas
tente de bâtir son avenir dans ce pays
encore nouveau pour lui
sur ce chantier c'est une aventure
humaine qui commence c'est bon les gens
m'ont bien accueilli
ils ont un grand coeur c'est une bonne
chose pour moi d'être ici c'est un vrai
travail d'équipé et j'aimerais vraiment
revenir en fait on est si mignon non c
c'est beaucoup trop sont ces lieux
oui c'est beaucoup trop foncé sur chaque
site
la restauration sait-on sur plusieurs
années des travaux qui serait impossible
sans l'aide des bénévoles car l'état ne
peut pas à lui seul gérer tout le
patrimoine dont nous avons hérité jade
se sont donc investi d'une mission
ma patrimoine c'est la trace du temps
d'un pays en fait d'accuser les traces
des hommes avant et du coup ça et en
important qu'on puisse la garder dans le
temps pour nous une génération future
enfin c'est ça la finalité de la
restauration du pouvoir la donner à nos
coûts prochaine génération
comme jade abbas et alexandra ils sont
chaque année des centaines en france a
consacré de leur temps pour sauvegarder
notre patrimoine
un enrichissement culturel tant pour ses
bénévoles que pour toutes les
générations qui profiteront un jour de
ses monuments
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur merci de m'accueillir y
avait un monde fou
[Musique]
e
on
m
claude vayssière pommeau merci de nous
accueillir avec votre épouse est
propriétaire de cette grande forge de
buffon un des lieux qui vont être aidées
normalement par le loto du patrimoine
qui aura lieu dans quelques jours ici en
côte d'or pas très loin de mon bar sur
les bords de l'armançon est-ce que vous
pouvez nous résumer en quelques mots
l'histoire de ce lieu convient de visite
et qu'on continue à visiter ensemble
c'est jason lui veut clair comte de
buffon a décidé d'installer une forge
même un ensemble de force parce qu'il y
avait la grande la petite forge dans le
village de griffon pour ça qu'il a
appris le nom de buffon et cette forge
c'est une usine moderne qu'il a voulu
réaliser pour faire ses expériences
scientifiques et aussi pour faire une
opération commerciale et montrer qu'avec
du minerai de pas très bonne qualité
vous pouvez en effet à faire du fer de
bonne qualité alors vous vous êtes par
héritage de votre épouse propriétaires
de ce qui est un monument historique
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est difficile
d'être propriétaires privés d'un
monument comme celui là le monument est
comme très important vous avez pu voir
la surface on est sur un terrain qui
maintenant ne fait que 14 hectares mais
surtout il ya deux parties de la partie
domestique qui se trouve sur le plateau
est ici la partie industrielle qui en
contrebas en plus des bâtiments des
monuments historiques dont la pierre les
constructions ont là tout le problème
hydraulique qui se posent
ça veut dire que vous êtes en permanence
en train de chercher des ressources de
financement à ce qu'on imagine que votre
retraite ne permet pas de restaurer et
d'entretenir tous à le retraite permet
de vivre peut-être pas de restaurer
effectivement des bâtiments et surtout
permet pas de restaurer des roues et un
barrage soit la mention qui a un ouvrage
monumental que buffon a créé et qu'il
faut à tout lui resterait actuellement
est-ce que c'est facile de dire aux
entreprises aux particuliers aussi aidez
nous à financer un patrimoine qui est
une propriété privée
est-ce que les gens comprennent ça parce
que un château au public une église
j'ai réparé une collectivité on pourrait
comprendre c'est le bien de tous et la
connaissance et le pape lui - 2
8e qui est présent et les jeux ne sont
pas ses yeux lorsqu'il voit des routes
fonctionner la petite roue de la
fonderie
elle s'est arrêtée le 15 août dernier et
parce que l'accès était fausse et on a
fait réparer d'urgence parce qu'on
voulait que elle fonctionne pour les
jeux il pas plus loin parce qu'elles
sont sans hydraulique pas de forge
exactement sans eau pas de force
aujourd'hui deux plateformes
et si jamais le barachois la bande-son
venait à ne plus fonctionner irait
plutôt ici donc les plus forts
[Musique]
e
est-ce que ça attire vraiment les dons
le mécénat comme pourrait le faire un
château une église pour l'instant au
point de vue dont on n'a eu que huit
américains
french de l'état société qui nous ont
donné 20 mille dollars
jamais les américains le patrimoine
syrie savent ce que c'est voilà comment
est ce que vous avez accueilli le fait
de vous retrouver dans la liste de
stéphane bern pour sur l'auto du
patrimoine
c'est une surprise et on était très
heureux de figurer parmi les 259 croit
aux bonnes manières et du coup ça va
vous permettre de réaliser peut-être
l'un de vos rêves
oui va remettre en marche la grande roue
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure la grande roue
est aussi le barrage sur la rançon qui
est un travail considérable tuffeau tout
plu lancée parce que buffon l'a
construit ce barrage ça lui permettait
de réguler l'eau dont elle avait besoin
dans sa forge c'est tout le mal qu'on
vous souhaite
merci
je
direction maintenant salins-les-bains
durant des siècles grâce au sel la
commune fut la capitale économique de
franche-comté témoigne de cette
splendeur hôtel particulier églises
chapelles et jardins aujourd'hui
personne n'a les moyens d'entretenir ce
patrimoine ni la commune ni les
propriétaires privés
et si pourtant c'était la clé de son
renouveau touristique et économique
[Musique]
je me demande de faire face à vos
responsabilités bien sûr vous avez
acheté il ya quatre ans vous deviez
rénové vous avez laissé le bien courir
aux gens non audité comme ça gêne
aujourd'hui non monsieur nous avons des
photos
aujourd'hui on était comme aujourd'hui
nantes et dans l'ain jour nuit les est
un danger pour vos voisins
il est très en colère le maire de sel 1
face aux propriétaires d'une maison dont
le toit vient de s'écrouler
cas typique on achète et on n'a pas
l'argent pour restaurer plus tordus
celui qui devient propriétaire d'un
immeuble ne loue pas volontairement les
appartements et ainsi profite de la
défiscalisation
il laisse tomber en ruines sont bien
tout simplement parce qu'à une
disposition fiscale qui lui permet de
défalquer les loyers qu'ils ne touchent
pas on en a deux ou trois comme ça donc
on va aller vers de la coercition c'est
à dire que on lui propose des aides pour
rénover
s'il ne veut pas rénové nous allons
aller jusqu'à l'expropriation et oui
gilles beder et quelquefois obligé de
prendre des décisions très impopulaire
il a même fermé une église l'église
saint-maurice qui a des moellons qui ont
commencé à tomber du plafond et qui
aurait pu être dangereux pour les
fidèles donc je nous avons décidé de
fermer cette église pour des raisons de
sécurité faut-il resterait saint maurice
d'ailleurs quel bâtiment gardé lesquels
démolir et surtout en fonction de quels
critères
cruel dilemme
aujourd'hui quand on traverse salins on
voit surtout ses façades grises et
bâtiments en piteux état
ces magasins fermés et pourtant
quatre mille ans avant jésus-christ le
sel est déjà exploité ici
ce gisement le plus important d'europe
fait la fortune de la ville durant
plusieurs siècles
un signe qui ne trompe pas salle 1 p
énormément d'impôts ce sera le poumon
économique de la province de du comté de
bourgogne puisque la ville de sanaa
contribuer pour moitié à la contribution
générale de la franche-comté voyage à
une gigantesque 17 congrégations
religieuses vivent dans cette ville
fortifiée
[Musique]
même les templiers ils possèdent leur
chapelle avec à sa tête jacques de molay
il deviendra le dernier grand maître et
mourra sur le bûcher
[Musique]
au xviie siècle les salinois érige notre
dame libératrice en remerciement à la
vierge pour les avoir protégés des
mercenaires du roi de france
tout ça là raconte un passé prestigieux
les églises des fontaines des hôtels
particuliers avec des jardins
magnifiques même certains escaliers
dette du moyen-âge un chantier de jeunes
les restaure alors bonjour
c'est les mêmes travailleurs film un
salaire d'avancé c'est superbe
et là vous imaginez pas le bonheur que
vous allez rendre aux salines noir parce
que c'est leur escalier mythique et on
s'était engagés à le restaurer et je
pense qu'en deux ou trois fois on va
peut être y arriver
oui il faudra bien plusieurs étés pour
finir cette restauration
vous vous promenez dans salins est ce
que vous voyez la beauté des bâtiments
où le coût que cela représente pour la
municipalité et les deux le patrimoine
est à la fois une charge et surtout une
grande chance à condition de prendre le
problème à bras le corps de l'étaler
dans le temps parce que nous n'avons
évidemment pas forcément les moyens de
tout faire tout de suite
mais oui pour moi le patrimoine c'est
une porte d'entrée de revitalisation
c'est ce que j'ai demandé à mes services
ce chiffre est moins ce qu'il faut
dépenser pour tout refaire
nous arrivons entre 64 et 70 millions
d'euros
[Musique]
concernant les trois églises une seule
certitude notre dame libératrice sera
rénové coup quatre cent mille euros
puis le conseil municipal et les
paroissiens devront choisir entre deux
bâtiments à restaurer sa maurice pour 2
millions d'euros ou sainte anne à toile
pour un million faire des choix toujours
cruel dilemme
exemple avec ce pâté de maison à
réhabiliter
magali bresson étudiante en architecture
présente son étude
après 18 mois de travail à deux membres
du conseil municipal
j'ai surtout retenu une phrase dans
l'habitant rencontré pas très loin d'ici
dans la rue de la liberté et qui disait
pour parler de sa land extérieur ses
anciennes maisons elle paye pas de mine
mais à l'intérieur on a des pépites
ça a été des lans questionnement sur
qu'est-ce qu'on conserve qu'est-ce qu'on
modifie qu'est ce qu'on va voilà mettre
en évidence sa proposition des
appartements duplex une supérette en
élargissant la rue et donc en détruisant
les façades
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit bien
nécessaire de tout démolir vous trouvez
c'est un peu trop radicales comme au
projet oui c'est ma grosse émission
c'est notre conception qui n'ont pas
forcément de génération ii peut-être de
sensibilité au patrimoine
là par exemple sacrifier cette belle
ensemble de façade
je ne le ferai pas ici c'est arcade
elles sont 15e ou 16e et donc c'est il y
a des choses des pépites aussi oui
qu'ils font sans ce qu'ils font aussi
partie de l'identité de will et rue de
salam en nature cessé de retard que tous
soient un comme ça beaucoup de réflexion
et d'argent seront encore nécessaires
pour que ce projet se concrétise enfin
faire du patrimoine à tous ces trois
professionnels du tourisme ont joué
cette carte la piraterie ce génie les
tous de napoléon iii venait prendre les
eaux à salins le gérant de l'hôtel des
bains à restaurer la pièce où elle
recevait un servette dépotoir exact
droit je sais par amour aussi du
patrimoine on peut pas laisser une salle
comme celle ci dans un pour cet état
dans l'état où elle était du moins
robert d'été à craquer lui pour le fort
saint-andré de vauban dans ce lieu ils
accueillent séminaires et mariage enfant
j'étais passionné par louis xiv par
toute l'histoire de france l'histoire de
france en général donc dès qu'on rentre
dans un même bâtiment faux ben on se dit
waouh
j'ai une chance inouïe quoi donc voilà
on réalise ce rêve de rentrer presque un
petit peu dans l'histoire c'est ancienne
scierie a été transformé en maison doute
après un premier raid et d'exploitation
son propriétaire est ravi que c'était
tellement beau qu'on avait envie de
montrer aux gens ce qui avait été fait
c'était tellement dommage que cette
partie de l'histoire disparaissent à
cause de travaux qu'on n'aurait pas fait
que là on est vraiment tombé amoureux et
puis on s'y sent bien on sent que c'est
comme si les gens ils étaient encore là
qui travaillèrent einer par l'estomac
des frissons le salon et jenny le fort
saint-andré l'ancienne scierie ont
trouvé un équilibre entre passé et
modernité
aujourd'hui ces lieux vivent une
nouvelle existence
des exemples à suivre le patrimoine doit
être entretenu des doit être sur mes
yeux bien sûr entretenu habitées on peut
aussi l'adapter l'art de vivre
d'aujourd'hui ce qui est important et
puis tout en conservant l'essentiel de
la richesse patrimoniale vous voulez pas
en faire un musée de sedin beaucoup non
ce serait une catastrophe si on a fait
ça l'amusé il faut justement que le
patrimoine soit vivant
au pied du mur mais forte de son passé
glorieux
c'est l'un veut croire en sa renaissance
[Musique]
jbl vous êtes le délégué régional de la
fondation du patrimoine ce que vous
pouvez nous dire en quelques mots quelle
est la mission de cette fondation la
fondation du patrimoine a été créée en
fin de compte
suite à la dernière où il a fallu
reconstruire et où le bâtiment a utilisé
le parpaing et le ciment et où le
bâtiment sien n'a plus aucune valeur
donc on s'est aperçu que nos frères nos
grands jeunes au pigeonnier nous la voir
tomber en ruine parce que ça n'avait pas
de valeur et ce qui était important
c'était la nouvelle génération de
bâtiments et puis un beau jour dans les
années 90 on s'est dit mais au fait tout
ceci ça avait de la valeur parce que nos
anciens savaient construire nos anciens
utilisaient des produits locaux nos
anciens savaient orienter les maisons
loos ancien savez utiliser la chaux et
c'est donc c'est dire on est en train de
perdre une beauté d'une beauté de la
france une beauté de notre patrimoine
est en train de perdre des savoir faire
donc il était utile de faire quelque
chose alors on est allé voir nos amis
anglais du national trust comme vous le
savez les aux amis anglais sont
extrêmement performants sur la
problématique du patrimoine a il été
décidé de créer par une loi la fondation
du patrimoine
en fin de compte une fondation de droit
privé d'accord mais qui donc est chargé
de récolter des fonds alors financer
certains points dans le métier c'est
d'aider au financement de projets de
restauration de patrimoine
ça peut être une péniche comme vous avez
pu voir à saint-jean-de-losne et c'est
tant au niveau de personnes privées que
de collectivités et de ce fait là où on
a deux dispositifs un dispositif qui
s'appelle le label pour les
propriétaires privés et un dispositif
pour les collectivités qui s'appelle la
souscription est alors avec cette
mission lancée par emmanuel macron il
confié à stéphane bern
vous êtes devenu en quelque sorte le
bras armé sur le terrain de la mission
de stéphane bern parce qu'il fallait
innover pas tout faire tout seul
oui c'est c'est pas faux on est devenu
le bras armé tout temps
on fait très attention en disant nous
sommes le bras armé parce que sur le
sujet patrimoine il faut savoir partager
d'accord il ya d'autres institutions qui
s'occupent du patrimoine et on l'a vu
pendant toute cette émission c'est à
dire que des gens qui s'occupent du
patrimoine des passionnés et des
bénévoles des associations des
collectivités etc
il y en a plein il n'y a pas que la
mission de stéphane dayre mais c'est
l'actualité et donc voulu filer un petit
coup de main on lui file un petit coup
de main on lui file un petit coup de
main pour la gestion financière des
dossiers d'accord mais ceci étant nous
restons amis avec la demeure historique
nous restons amis avec vieilles maisons
françaises etc
nous restons amis avec le centre des
monuments nationaux pour faire en sorte
que ce soit pas une hégémonie de la
fondation du patrimoine au nom de
stéphane bern
[Musique]
et m
coc
[Musique]
alors comment vous avez accueilli ce
projet de stéphane bern de créer un loto
du patrimoine vous et tout ce qu'on a vu
dans cette émission qui travaille depuis
des années à la sauvegarde du patrimoine
c'est quoi c'est une bonne nouvelle
c'est un coup médiatique comment est-ce
qu'on vous comment est ce qu'on pourrait
dire les choses
1 c'est une bonne nouvelle puisque en
fin de compte on va avoir des fonds
supplémentaires pour le patrimoine
et ça c'est toujours une excellente
nouvelle par contre il faut pas que ce
soit l'arbre qui cache la forêt parce
qu'en fin de compte on s'aperçoit pour
la région bourgogne franche comté qu'on
a plusieurs centaines de projets de
collectivités de propriétaires privés
donc là on va avoir au niveau national
une quinzaine de projets emblématiques
250 projets complémentaires mais
derrière il faut pas oublier les autres
ceci étant je crois que le sujet
patrimoine est devenue nationale
je crois que c'est grâce à l'action de
stéphane bern l'action du président de
la république qui ont fait que on lance
un loto du patrimoine qui va financer un
certain nombre d'actions pourtant on le
sait et les journées européennes du
patrimoine arrive on le sait les
français aiment leur patrie mois ils
sont attachés à leur patrimoine
pour autant ils mettent pas forcément la
main à la poche pour le sauver c'est
sale c'est ça la différence que vous
soyez la différence c'est qu'on va avoir
un complément de main à la poche des
français par l'intermédiaire de certains
le font déjà certains le font déjà il
faut savoir que la région bourgogne
franche comté on a quand même collecté
l'an dernier plus d'un million six cent
soixante cinq mille euros et quand je
dis on s'est bien entendu l'ensemble des
personnes privées l'ensemble des
entreprises et l'ensemble des
associations des collectivités qui ont
le vrai pour dire on a besoin de
restaurer notre patrimoine
on a des subventions mais en même temps
il faut compléter ces subventions par du
mécénat
alors là c'est sur l'auto du patrimoine
avec ses sites emblématiques comme le
château de bussy-rabutin où on se trouve
aujourd'hui c'est une façon de
communiquer pour dire aux gens vous
pouvez aussi très concrètement aider
vous pouvez venir le voir aux journées
du patrimoine le patrimoine et certaines
fois tout le reste de l'année mais pas
seulement vous pouvez vous aussi
contribué à sa sauvegarde tout à fait et
puis vous avez avoir des jeux à gratter
bon à 15 euros mais un dirt 50 va
revenir 12 millions de jeux à gratter 1
euro 50 pour chaque jeu à gratter pour
le patrimoine plus le loto qui va
permettre si vous voulez d'apporter une
part complémentaire aussi bien sur la
partie fixe que la partie
proportionnelle aux montants collectés
c'est la bonne idée de stéphane bern
c'est vrai que on n'y avait pas en
france ça ne s'était pas encore fait ce
nom
ce loto du patrimoine mais ça n'est pas
la seule idée pour faire des choses pour
le patrimoine vous nous le confirmer oui
tout à fait je reviens un petit peu sur
le patrimoine privé parce que vous
m'avez parlé de salins par exemple oui
on va savoir ce qu'on essaye de faire si
vous voulez de plus en plus c'est de
montrer que la restauration du
patrimoine privé contribue à
l'attractivité des collectivités et
c'est pour ça qu'à salins par exemple on
a fait un fond façade et se font façade
permet d'encourager les propriétaires
privés pour la beauté de la commune de
salins et vous avez pu remarquer qu'il
ya un certain nombre de petites choses à
faire à salah oui je crois que c'est un
dispositif collectif la restauration du
patrimoine privé et on le fait dans un
gîte à fait saber valeurs aussi des
personnes modestes mais qui ont un coeur
de restaurer leur patrimoine
et ça c'est aussi important le
patrimoine c'est pas que le château de
bussy-rabutin ça peut être des édifices
plus modestes et je crois que c'est ça
aussi notre patrimoine pour parler de
l'attractivité de notre région
[Musique]
parmi ces passionnés de patrimoine dont
on nous parle depuis le début de cette
émission il ya les artisans d'art 38
mille entreprises en france pour la
quasi-totalité des tpe des très petites
entreprises
beaucoup d'entre eux travaillent presque
exclusivement pour la restauration et la
sauvegarde de notre patrimoine
nous en avons rencontré trois dans notre
région des mains en or ils sont ébéniste
couvreurs ou maîtres verriers et depuis
des décennies leur savoir-faire a fait
d'eux des artisans de renom des artisans
au service du patrimoine qu'ils
travaillent seuls ou en équipes ils sont
tous animés par la même passion leur
métier au beau milieu de la côte
chalonnaise entonna bouchard a installé
son atelier il ya plus de 30 ans dans le
domaine viticole familial ébéniste
depuis quatre décennies
il est spécialisé dans le mobilier du
12e au xviie siècle alors antonin vous
travaillez voilà sur la restauration
d'un coffre anglo normand et début du
16e qui enchaîne manier parce qu'en fait
c'est un chêne qui est tranché sur
quartier et pour ça il faut du bois
anciens justement à grain fin pour
pouvoir permettre d'avoir une belle
restauration des meubles comme ça ils
ont été restaurées au 19e ou départ
c'était un coffre ils en ont fait un
placard parce que c'était pas pratique
donc ils ont mis deux portes et
le but c'est de le remettre dans
l'esprit où ils étaient 500 heures de
travail seront nécessaires pour la
restauration de ce qu'offre une pièce
d'exception démonstration d'un
savoir-faire principale clientèle
d'antonin les particuliers un marché
difficile
la restauration de monde en effet
beaucoup de temps et de main d'oeuvre il
à l'addition peut vite grimper manager
quelques meubles surfer vue là par
exemple j'ai fait un effet y en a pour
1200 euros ttc à peu près pour un petit
meuble qui dans une salle des ventes
coûterait peut-être 300 euros mais bon
les clients y tiennent donc
j'attends le
leur accord avant de l'attaquer des
travaux de restauration mais aussi
création
antonin travaille actuellement sur des
fenêtres destinées aux hospices de
beaune
s'il est sollicité régulièrement pour la
sauvegarde du patrimoine bâti là
quelques regrets concernant le mobilier
est un peu le parent pauvre mon problème
c'est que on laisse dans l'état faut pas
y toucher
on montre pas les partis qui ont été
refaites et un tableau on va passer du
temps dessus on va faire des études
supérieures à 130 km de là en côte d'or
un chantier d'envergure l'église de
poncey sur lignon se refait une beauté
au coeur des attentions la toiture en
lave de pierre une singularité
architecturale pour la bourgogne
depuis l'été 2010 est antonio répondent
aux couvreurs lavier travaillent sur ce
chantier avec son fils thomas et arnold
son ouvrier à taille de la pierre calage
les gestes son furet d'une apparente
simplicité
pourtant le travail de la lawe requiert
une grande dextérité
attention la pierre de lave n'a ici rien
de volcaniques
elle doit son nom à l'expression pierre
levée c'est à dire extraites en surface
que la lave c'est que c'est que de la
prestation c'est que de là un marteau
puis on fait tout de a à z
on fait des les rives où les arrêter les
nous enfin que peuple à tulle il faut il
faut croiser chaque accessoire que là on
le transforme chaque paire en 10,2 à z
on peut faire le métier et il vous
annonce quoi c'est tout citect maire de
la commune un jaune la drac
aujourd'hui c'est le jour de la visite
du chantier et antonio signale un
problème de taille la carrière n'a plus
de stock pour trouver des grands formats
en 3 5 c'est difficile au même endroit
mais on sait que vous êtes exigeant que
je retiens c'est qu'on ne peut rien vous
refusez initiée par madame le maire ce
chantier supervisé par frédéric didier
architecte en chef des monuments
historiques
il est notamment en charge de versailles
vous pour lui entre cette église et le
château du roi soleil
la relation est évidente le lien c'est
l'excellence et la beauté de toute façon
il n'ya pas de petit patrimoine ya du
patrimoine et est ce que vous avez là
c'est vraiment l'expression de à la fois
d'un art d'une technique d'une beauté
d'une intelligence à travers les siècles
huit cent mille euros c'est le montant
du lifting de cette église du xviiie
siècle
financé à 90% par l'état le département
ce type de chantier ne sauvegarde pas
uniquement le patrimoine
c'est un conservatoire des techniques ça
c'est très très important parce que
sinon la restauration du patronat ça
deviendra comme le latin c'est une
langue morte
et le jour où c'est une langue morte on
peut plus le faire cirque est ce qu'on
fera on saura plus faire et ça c'est une
technique qui a failli se perdre
les bleus indiens et transmission d'un
savoir faire c'est aussi la
préoccupation d'antonio après dix années
de collaboration son fils va reprendre
le flambeau
non sans appréhension et j'espère que
oui
au niveau des chantiers tout ça va durer
près ça coûte tellement cher à l'oeuvre
que la peau grande qui peut se procurer
un pot commun particulier par exemple
avoir beaucoup de subventions
chez les retombées la troisième
génération est déjà en formation
gianni cinq ans devra encore attendre
quelques années pour monter sur un toit
[Musique]
strasbourg
et sa cathédrale au style gothique
flamboyant après la restauration des
rosaces de la façade sud en côte d'or
les ateliers part au travail depuis
plusieurs semaines sur les vitraux de
l'horloge
ces deux saints chevaliers du 12e et 19e
siècles sont bientôt prêt à retrouver
l'alsace en pierres on va regarder
surtout les collages et les comblements
si elles ont été faits dans les dents ce
qu'on avait prévu
7les cela doit être inversée faudra
qu'on regarde ça c'est un choix parce
que regarde le tiffany le la casse était
là et là ce que la pièce et réinverser
pierre-alain parrot et tout comme son
père avant lui
maître verrier son atelier basé à 20 km
de dijon est l'un des quatre plus grands
de france spécialisée dans la
restauration il emploie 14 salariés dont
sa fille m -cd chimiques ou action
mécanique des remèdes parmi d'autres ici
les blouses blanches sont au chevet des
oeuvres d'art l'objectif atténuer les
effets du temps tout en préservant un
ouvrage aujourd'hui c'est la
conservation maximale on ne regarde
l'histoire du vitra ici un bouche trou
si cette pièce là par exemple est dû et
du 16e siècle à côté d'une pièce du 12e
et on va la laisser évidemment on sait
ça fait partie de l'histoire du vitrail
danse et la conservation maximale après
le nettoyage place au collage au fil du
temps des plombs ont été parfois
ajoutées pour réparer des verres cassés
aujourd'hui une résine permet de
supprimer les plombs superflu c'est la
spécialité d'arnaud mais aussi sa plus
grande fierté
ce que j'adore en fait c'est redonner
une lecture du vitrail
avec les restaurations de passer il ya
souvent beaucoup de plomb qui cas les
pièces ont été cassés on ne comprend
plus rien il ya plus de lecture est là
quand ça passe à la phase collage on
redonne une lecture c'est ce que je
préfère
arnaud comme la plupart des salariés a
été formé ici
frédéric lui est passé par lyon et
valence il s'occupe de la remise en
plomb avec plus de vingt ans de métier
le vitrail et toujours pour lui une
passion de la ferronnerie de la
serrurerie à la taille de pierre il ya
du montage et de la coupe c'est quelque
chose de comment dire c'est très
complets tout en étant assez compliqué
c'est pour ça qu'on met beaucoup de
temps à être formés puisqu'on touche à
beaucoup de choses qui à chaque vitrail
chaque église chaque réalisation à
apporte une connaissance encore qu'on a
à cosnac et au fur et à mesure donc nous
on considère que fo paieront 10 à 12 ans
pratique vraiment dans un atelier comme
ici pourra pour maîtriser prendre une
certaine autonomie et une autonomie un
jeu made in maîtrise une autonomie
vraiment pour confier à un travail
complet transmettre son savoir faire et
par là même sa passion c'est l'une des
préoccupations de ses artisans
si les prétendants ne ment pas la baisse
du pouvoir d'achat des particuliers et
le recul des dotations de l'état ont
fragilisé le secteur
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouve bien sûr le mois prochain pour
un nouveau numéro d' enquête de région
et d'ici là surtout prenez soin de vous
mon
[Musique]